it is absolutely vital that the truth  comes out on what happened to mr.  Freddie gray and it is my practice not  to comment on the legal processes  involved that would not be appropriate  but I can tell you that justice needs to  be served all the evidence needs to be  presented those individuals who are  charged obviously are also entitled to  due process and rule of law and so you  know I want to make sure that our legal  system runs the way it should and the  Justice Department and our new Attorney  General is in communications with  Baltimore officials to make sure that  any assistance we can provide on the  investigation is provided but what I  think the people of Baltimore want more  than anything else is the truth that's  what people around the country expect  and to the extent that it's appropriate  this administration will help local  officials get to the bottom of exactly  what happened